إنها تشير إلى مرور
الوقت وتغير الفصول
وفضاء الأرض
، عالم من الأفكار ملفوف في تعبير ضئيل
عن حلاوة
واغاشي الحلويات اليابانية التقليدية
والإشادة المصنوعة يدويًا بعلاقاتنا مع
الطبيعة بهجة الانتقال بين الفصول الأربعة
هو شيء أصبحنا نحن
اليابانيين نحبه ،
وأعتقد أنه مدمج في الحمض النووي الخاص
بنا ، وقد تدرس شيهو ساكاموتو
فن واغاشي على مدار العقد الماضي من
أجل حلوياتها ، فهي تستخدم المكونات التقليدية
مثل حبوب أزوكي المستخدمة في معجون الفاصوليا الحمراء
يسمى
عم كونتين نوعًا  من الجيلاتين المشتق
من غليان الأعشاب
البحرية وبالطبع مجموعة من السكريات ذات
الجذور في القرن السابع عشر ،
تم إنشاء واغاشي خلال فترة إيدو في
فترة
التطور الثقافي الهائل
لليابان
، وأصبح من التقاليد تناول الشاي في
واغاشي للاحتفال بالموسم القادم
للأجنحة  ستمنحك شعورًا مشرقًا للغاية
لأنها تمنح الناس القوة
للمضي قدمًا
وتقول إنها تهدف إلى أن تكون دقيقًا في ر
اختيار المكونات التي
تستخدمها واغاشي كرة من الفاصوليا البيضاء
مغلفة بمحتوى بلوري
مستوحاة من قطرات المطر
[موسيقى
] أردت إظهار جمال المطر في
هذا
التصميم وكيف يمكن لقطرة واحدة من المطر إثراء
توراة الأرض تعني نمر
و  نعم يعني التسوق ، لذا فإن
اسمنا يعني حرفياً متجر النمر
البالغ من العمر 35 عامًا
ميتسوهارو كوروكاوا هو
الوكيل الحالي لواحد من أكثر
شركات صناعة الواغاشي اليابانية شهرة في
شركة Toriya للحلويات
الآن في جيلها الثامن عشر الذي بدأناه في
kyoto
منذ حوالي 500 عام ، أحد الأشياء هو أنه
نحن نقدم الحلويات
للعائلة المالكة في اليابان منذ أكثر من 500
عام ونصنع معظم حلوياتنا
بمكونات نباتية
تأسست في kyoto في القرن السادس عشر ،
تمتلك الشركة الآن عشرات المتاجر في جميع أنحاء
اليابان
وموقع في باريس ولرئيس toriya
الذي يحمل  إن ثقل تاريخ عائلته
الممتد على مدى 500 عام في واغاشي يشق
طريقًا إلى الأمام يعني
الاستعداد
للتجربة ونشر الحلويات  rt
خارج حدود اليابان ،
أرث ما بناه أي شخص آخر ،
أشعر بالمسؤولية في الاستمرار
ونقل أيضًا إلى الجيل التالي
، وأرغب في جعل Toraya وأيضًا
الواغاشي تصبح شيئًا أكثر عالمية